part reason why i think that some
um merit to dogecoin even though it was
obviously created as a joke
um
is that
it it actually does have a much higher
uh transaction volume capability than
bitcoin um
and the you know the cut like the costs
of doing a transaction the the the dodge
coin fee is is very low like right now
if you want to do a bitcoin transaction
the price of doing that transaction is
very high so you could not use it
effectively for most things
and nor could it even scale to a high
volume
um
uh
and when bitcoin was you know started i
guess when around 2008 or something like
that um
the internet connections were much worse
than they are today like order of
magnitude couple
i mean there's the way way worse you
know in 2008 so so like having us you
know a small
uh block size or whatever is
you know and a long
synchronization time is
made sense in 2008 but did you know 2021
or fast forward 10 years it's like it's
it's like
comically low you know it's uh
so
um
and i think there's some
value to
having
a linear increase in the amount of
currency that uh is generated um
so because some amount of the currency
you'd like like
if if
if a currency is too deflationary or
like uh or should say if if if a
currency is expected to increase in
value over time there's reluctance to
spend it
because they're like oh i if i
i'll just hold it and not spend it
because it's scarcity is increasing with
time so if i spend it now then i will
regress defending it so i will just you
know total it
um
but if there's
some dilution of the currency occurring
over time that's that's more of an
incentive to use it as a currency so um
those coins somewhat randomly has
uh a
um
just a fixed a number of
sort of coins or hash strings that
uh
are generated every year so there's
there's some
inflation but it's not a percentage base
it's a it's so that
it's a fixed number so the percentage of
inflation will necessarily decline over
time
um
so it just i'm not saying that it's like
the ideal system for a currency but i
think it actually is uh just
fundamentally better than
anything else i've seen just by accident
you